20:19 for me is the year of Facebook
like I'm gonna go all in on Facebook
because you got your prospective
[Music]
everybody in today's vlog I crush it in
Phoenix get on a plane and go to Atlanta
and go in studio with an artist that I
think is next I hope you enjoy the show
LinkedIn content organic is probably the
best platform for organic besides
Instagram and I think instagrams on the
beginning stages of like starting to
lose its organic value I'm starting to
believe that everybody has to have a
LinkedIn strategy I even told Jordan
who's a personal trainer this morning
I'm like you need to start making
LinkedIn content things like five-minute
workouts at the airport because that's
what business people would like hey guys
so in Phoenix during strategy sessions I
kind of really brought it Caleb my guy
here let me uh let me let me study her
Caleb Caleb here is trying to figure out
how to break it down so I'm entering him
he will post produce and figure out how
to path you after this I hope you enjoy
the bids here is like the story of
literally the moment that the economy
collapse in 2008 and I think there's
some really good moments to learn from
definitely take note and watch it two or
three times I woke up in the morning
that day I was in I was in France buying
line and Brandon calls me cuz if it's
early you know six hours ahead there it
happened in the morning Bear Stearns I
did it
Brendan calls me goes hey I was like hey
he's like we've had like four hundred
thousand dollars in pre-order wine
cancelled this morning like literally I
remember where I was I started buying
less wine like then I did the first two
days of the trip
and the first two days are tripping big
shot like am I don't take a hundred
cases of that I don't think fifteen case
of that literally an hour late I'm like
yeah this is not that great thanks for
your time so so yeah bro I would I would
hide and listen you're no dummy and and
I don't know I would have said the same
thing a year ago and nothing's happened
well actually something has listened
bass Facebook's Facebook's collapsed
I've lost a lot of money in the last you
know like but but I'm gonna buy and
because my
big thing is dead is awfully scary if
your business doesn't do well when the
economy collapses if yours does look I
think vaynermedia explodes I do because
I think when Aquafina wakes up and
realizes and it happens in a day
remember it takes 30 to 60 days for it
all to get figured out but it happens in
a day and when they get into a board
meeting on March 9th and are like okay
we had a we had 83 million in marketing
this year now that's been cut to 9
million what are we doing with that
money I have a funny feeling that
garyvee character might know what to do
with it way better than [ __ ] Madison
Avenue student who's critiquing me and
so I think we're gonna explode look if
we were partners I'd be like bro
honestly here's my plan
it's been so good for so long let's
actually be humble as [ __ ] let's just
let's just actually hoard cash you
understand a million dollars in your
bank account today in the world versus
what happens when the world melts that
millions worth like for and so like
it'll suck right now it sucks for me I'm
Lea I'm sitting around just watching
sitting on cash being like I'm an idiot
like right but I won't be at some point
it's gonna happen it's no different than
50 in a 50 year window I don't give a
[ __ ] it takes another four years
especially and this is how I hedged it
because I'm building a machine that
capitalizes on the other side so I would
actually tell you try to think about
that this is a moment where Gary talks
about the dangers of living in the
middle and how he believes on living in
the extremes one thing I'm obsessed with
is extremes if I started an events
business if I was like in the blowup
castle business to rent to like bar
mitzvahs and birthdays what I would do
tomorrow is go to [ __ ] in China and make
the most extreme castle of all time like
a 900 foot castle because what's
happening in our society right now is
its min ilysm and its extremism the
Middle's [ __ ] so I'm very hot on like
if you look at like the pop-up museums
in New York it's like extreme candy
extreme colors it's like you've got
these you know mocktails that are like
$39 but they steam out like go
extremists [ __ ] cuz the picture
it's the club dynamic why do clubs right
now have when you order the champagne
the sparklers come out and for the
people want attention they're not behind
the champagne they're buying the
attention they want every dude and girl
in the club to look at me like oh that's
the big baller anyway you can figure out
to be the most extreme err or the most
subtle don't live in don't live in the
middle the world is getting pulled that
way because of the Internet it's the
Middle's bad it's really huge and then
look at yourself to figure out who you
are the reason I think I work is I'm a
little bit of both right I'm very
outlandish in my communication style but
I'm very minimal in my likes right there
is no jewelry back to you said like
that's not who I am and if I was that's
cool I love authenticity and II froze
Ella loves Lamborghinis for real and so
that's cool and he can afford them and
he's not renting them to look cool to
like make you pay for a thousand dollar
course so like that's authentic
authenticity and left the right know
middle and as the last one from this
strategy session Gary talks about his
move on Facebook how he feels like
attentions moving from it and so he's
going all in on it
check it out something I'm super excited
I was telling Jordan while I was working
out this morning I texted Andy yesterday
2019 for me is the year of Facebook like
I'm gonna go all-in on Facebook cuz
everyone's kind of phasing out and I'm
gonna produce original content which is
unusual for me for the last couple years
strictly for 50 to 90 year olds strictly
original content just for 50 to 90 year
olds because I think I think I think it
to be very fertile grounds for Facebook
next year cuz I think a lot of the best
people are leaving because they feel
like it's not as good it's not as cool
it's you know Instagram and it just it's
the way I think about [ __ ] it's like
right Facebook
are you 49 years old and in a great
place in your career and it's working
whether you're an executive or you have
your own startup and it's going
extremely well you're making more money
than ever or on the verge of you're
making bigger impact it's growing
everything's right except you have five
year old Charlie at home you have six
year old Susan at home
I just really desperately need you to
understand that if you're 51 years old
right now and everything's going great
and you've worked so hard for it but you
are self-aware enough to know that you
need to be at these recitals and these
ballgames and you want to milk when they
get home from school that it is
remarkably right to take the foot off
the pedal for 12 13 14 years because
they're gonna be running off to college
so damn quick and let me remind you here
in this video Facebook that's 63 years
old 51 plus 12 six year old 12 years
going to college that's 63 years old is
a goddamn baby when it comes to business
and you have 20 incredible years of
career startup your mission your desire
if you're self-aware enough to know that
you need to take the pedal off the metal
and spend more time at home
and go do that deploy self-awareness
there is no right way there is no proper
work-life balance if that's what you
need not because your spouse said it or
because your friend said it or your
mum's gone but got eyes for you or a
motivational post on the Instagram
because that's what you know about
yourself then go do it and at the same
point if it's not then triple down on
that thing
work-life balance is individual but
understand that life is much longer than
people under recognize it is definitely
the shortcoming of the majority of
people you can't put time in perspective
so take the foot off the pedal if that's
what's in your heart now
[Applause]
the trick the unlock the place that you
will hear an enormous amount of
pontificating for me in 2019 will be
around the volume of content that you
produce for the 10 platforms over the
last year what has become unbelievably
obvious to me that works for me
thousands of other people and the brands
that are winning in society the
businesses that are growing the one
correlation that's just black and white
to me I just want to maximize the time
before I have to catch this play to
Atlanta so thank you for listening if
you don't have a very serious LinkedIn
content strategy you're leaving a huge
opportunity you're a young dude and
you're gonna gravitate towards eiji
video easy but LinkedIn is [ __ ] gold
right now for everybody LinkedIn organic
reach is more split this book organic
reach was doing five or six years ago it
is just an opportunity and I don't care
if you're selling weird t-shirts figure
out how to make it business oriented in
LinkedIn everybody here should really
think about how to make their content
work to professionals if you're in the
roofing business like title the posts
why lawyers and and an HR executives
need better roofs I'm not joking so I
for you bro heavy content a LinkedIn
before LinkedIn's organic reach starts
declining to where I've made my money
and where I've lost my money is on the
Delta of the two things that matter the
idea and then the timing of that idea
which you're gonna deal with with a I
and then honestly the thing that kept in
the beginning I was great at but then I
did get a little too high on my supply
off the winds and I started just betting
on the idea I was at my best and I'm
back to being that person when I bet on
the person to like that
I look the other way you know what I did
poorly I would hear a business idea and
I could glean what I would do if I was
running it and that's when I thought it
would be good but I didn't realize like
I'm not running it and so what makes the
success in my opinion is I believe in
the idea the ideas timing is right
because that's where people get killed
like AI is gonna happen when AR is gonna
happen when you know me people pour tons
of money into virtual reality 18 months
ago we're not even close
nobody here uses VR like so timing idea
human thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
see ya bye
[Music]
how are you gonna happen that's what I'm
good at whether it's Facebook or gonna
it's the same [ __ ] I just understand
what America likes yeah you know what I
mean it's just the same [ __ ] it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen you know what I
like the most Oh like we we look at a
lot of stuff there's a lot of people who
have sounds that can make it it's after
I started talking to both of them really
and this kids really got it he's got his
head on straight as [ __ ] which is really
which is really why you need to have
your head on straight because when it
happens fast man if your head on
straight it's over quit
yeah because money and like Fame and
opportunity exposes what's going on your
dome you know every time I hear people
like all the money changing I'm like you
got a twisted that's who he was
you just got exposed
[Music]
by all these people trying to do more
based on talks like they're just in
there comfortable doing like in that
conference room where Everton but your
industry with Mike Mike is like you know
saying that I think that's crazy
appreciate it man that's why the best
part is it feels so real - it feels so
natural to me and then I don't love you
more because of this because you're and
I'm just there and I'm trying to help ya
I'm not asking for anything I'm just
trying to get them exposure that's crazy
just give as big as he is just given the
authenticity is the only thing that
plays can't walk in that room and be
there to like [ __ ] and do the wrong
thing yeah you're gonna lose and not
like and just like be out of place and
not like speak it for sure man it's
you're exactly right like and the best
part is like we're making the
documentary like we're gonna watch this
film at nine and a half years on Netflix
or whatever the [ __ ] can be like you
know great day [ __ ] happy make it so
much happy
it just feels exactly right vlog I love
you thank you so much for watching this
[ __ ] this journey means a lot the
feedback the comments subscribe if you
haven't please
[Music]
no play
[Music]